يعني بمعنى انه ربنا بحاول لما كان في
ظراميل مسيحيتهم بقى عليها همم ايضا
اوروبا عانت من محاكم التفتيش ايضا اوروبا
عانت من الصراعات المذهبي بين المذهبين
الكبيرين الكاثوليكي والسنتي كانت معارك
طائفيه كانت مجازر لماذا
»
في القرن الثامن عشر انا اقفز من القرن
السادس عشر الى الثامن عشر
لماذا ظهرت تنوير في اوروبا
سهلبيه حاجه وهي ايجاد علاج للمجازر
للمذهبيه والطائفيه في اوروبا مثلا مرتين
همم مثلا المجازر اخرى كثيره الحروب
المذهبيه هي التي دفعت
اوروبا اذا همم بوابه سهم جديد
ونحن الان ايضا نعاني من من
مذهبيه معاني من التطرف نعاني من من
ظلمنيات وبالتالي هون في تشابه ما بين
الحادثه الاوروبيه قبل القرنين او ثلاثه
والحاله الاسلاميه او العربيه الان هناك
تشابه هناك همم والا انا همم من هذه
الناحيه استفيد من تجربه فولتير جون جاك
روسو
هؤلاء بالنسبه للمنارات همم استفيد كثيرا
لانهم نوروا شعوبهم اخرجوهم من حالي صاحب
الطائفي للدين الى الفهم همم تنوير للدين
من حاله الفهم التكفيري للدين كانوا
يكفرون بعضهم
البعضنتي بيكسر رغم انه كلهم
مع الوضع العربي لانه هناك ايضا تكسير بين
المذاهب الاسلاميه ونحن نحب ان نتجاوزها
وانا اشيد بهذه المناسبه
وثيقه الاخوه الانسانيه التي ستظهر في ابو
ظبي
وثيقه مكه المكرمه التي ظهرت في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
للاخرين هذا هذه المبادرات
قيمه وينبغي ان نشكرها نشكر القائمين
عليها سواء في في
ابو ظبي او في مكه المكرمه هذه المبادرات
تمشي في اتجاه
حركه التاريخ